cet après midi dans cette classe de
voisins-le-bretonneux session
particulière les élèves leurs
professeurs utilisent mon carnet de golf
un programme éducatif créé dans le cadre
de la ryder cup 2018 la coupe du monde
de la discipline qui s'organisait à
saint quentin en yvelines
objectif apprendre de façon ludique les
matières scolaires
on a deux thèmes généraux départ
découvrir le golf et découvrir la ryder
cup
donc je découvre je progresse
j'approche et je retiens lorsque les
enfants ont parcouru donc ces pages
ils ont déjà une culture assez étendue
par rapport au thème c'est c'est
vraiment bénéfique
après avoir testé la première version du
carnet de golf en 2015 la professeur n'a
pas hésité à renouveler l'expérience
pour cette nouvelle année scolaire afin
de stimuler les élèves
c'est évident que d'avoir en fil rouge
un projet dans la classe qui plusieurs
projets sportifs parce que les enfants
aiment beaucoup le sport beaucoup
d'activités sportives
ça permet vraiment de calais d
apprentissage sans que la difficulté ou
tout ce qui est trop abstrait où tout ce
qui est trop technique ne prenne le
dessus des apprentissages qui se font
tout seuls sans que les élèves ne soient
bloqués par l'aspect trop théorique en
fait de l'apprentissage
une recette qui fonctionne les 26 élèves
de cette classe plébiscitent ce
programme d'enseignement créée par la
fédération française 50 ans divine et
l'éducation nationale
on apprend de l'anglais un peu de maths
et ça nous apprend on travaille en même
temps on joue parce que c'est marrant
[Musique]
l'après midi s'est terminé par une
cession de golf l'occasion de mettre en
pratique leurs acquis de s'entraîner en
vue de fouler le green de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines une sortie
scolaire est programmée d'ici la fin de
l'année